Ukraine has regained more than 50% of
the territory Russian troops once
occupied back by us Le Coalition of more
than 50 countries around the world all
doing its part to support ke I'm going
to look it up right now what would
happen if we walked
away we are the essential
Nation meanwhile Putin has turned to
Iran and North Korea to buy attack
drones and ammunition to terrorize
Ukrainian cities and people from the
outset I've said I will not send
American troops to fight Ukraine all
Ukraine is asking for is help for the
weapons to push invading Russian forces
off their land mou bid and the air
defense system to shoot down Russian
missiles before they destroy Ukrainian
cities let me be clear about I don't
care we send equipment sitting in our
stockpiles and when we use the money
allocated by Congress we to rep